[Music]
let's talk about compromise both
personal compromise and national
compromise in a marriage you have to
make compromises a friend of mine with a
happy marriage said the best you can
hope for in a marriage is agreement on
80 percent if you agree on 80% that's
fantastic nobody is ever going to agree
on 99 percent and so every couple is
going to have to compromise about
something maybe they agree about sex
children and money but they got a
compromise on the in-laws
maybe they agree on in-laws sex sex and
money but they disagree about what they
can have for breakfast
so you have to have compromise in a
marriage you also have have to have
compromise in a country it's especially
the essence of a democracy this is
something worth restating for the United
States today because during much of my
lifetime our elected representatives and
our electorates succeeded in reaching
compromise about difficult issues but
political compromises sadly breaking
down today the most recent congresses in
the united states have passed fewer laws
than any other Congress in American
history they can't reach agreement in
the 1980's President Reagan and the
Democratic House leadership Tip O'Neill
they disagreed strongly in their
politics but they respected each other
and they reach compromises and they got
big pieces of legislation passed the
legislation was not exactly what Tip
O'Neill wanted it wasn't what Ronald
Reagan wanted but it was a satisfactory
compromise and they passed some
legislation nowadays our Congress is not
passing legislation our executive our
president is at loggerheads with the
lower house of Congress within each
political party there are the radical
and the central centrist wings our
legislature our executive are at odds
with our judiciary the legislature of
the state of West Virginia don't laugh
when I say this the legislature of West
Virginia has impeached every justice on
the Supreme Court of West Virginia why
supposedly because they spend thirty
thousand dollars to buy
new sofas for their office but there are
more fundamental things
there's breakdown of compromise between
the steak of them the national
government my state California is busy
suing the federal government because the
federal government is busy suing the
state of California so political
compromise is breaking down in the
United States today we can discuss the
reasons for but to me that is the most
serious problem of the United States
faces it's the only problem that could
precipitate the United States into the
end of democracy and into a dictatorship
in the next decade the United States is
not the first country in human history
to have a breakdown of political
compromise other countries have faced it
as well an example that I experienced
firsthand was the South American country
of Chile where I lived in 1967 Chile has
been the most democratic country in
Latin America when I moved to Chile in
1967 and my Chilean friends wanted to
explain to the American visitor what our
country was is like while Chilean
friends said we are not like those other
Latin American countries we are a
democracy we know how to govern
ourselves that was 1967 but Chile was in
the middle of a decline of political
compromise which exploded in 1973 with a
military coupe the military government
stayed in power for 17 years
smashed world records for sadists and
the torture and for me and for Chileans
and it should be for Americans it was a
wake-up call because it shows how a
functioning democracy can decay within a
relatively short time into a vicious
dictatorship this is the risk that I see
for the United States in the United
States if democracy ends with us is not
going to be by a military coup because
the American army has never been
involved in politics instead that the
decay of democracy in the United States
will be by what we see going on now the
restrictions placed on voter
registration we're the party in power
locally or in a state prevent citizens
likely to vote for the other party from
voting it will come about because those
citizens who are registered to vote
can't be bothered to vote in the most
recent election for
mayor of my city Los Angeles Los Angeles
is one of the most important cities in
the United States and the mayor of Los
Angeles was most port elected position
in Los Angeles in our last election for
mayor
80% of Los Angelenos couldn't be
bothered to vote for mayor 20% voted for
mayor so if if we don't like our mayor
it's our fault for not having voted for
our neighborhood well what can we do
about dealing with our political
compromise the first thing you can do is
vote if you don't like your government
it's your own fault if you didn't vote
the second thing we can do is to
complain loudly when you see one party
restricting vote for another party and
there are other things but that will do
as a starter
[Music]
you